パンカラジオ
さようならさようなら
俺は根助普段は小学校に通っている普通の小学生だが
きー殺人よ
やばいっていたぞ
こんなダイングメッセージが
これは事件だこのダイグメッセージたぬきの絵が書いてあるつまりタオ抜く暗号犯人はハゲお前だ
[音楽]
えちょちょちょ
え、真実はあいつも人くそうだよ。俺が殺したんだ。俺が犯人だ。
[音楽]
大砲。実は日々事件を解決している探偵。
その名も名探偵根。
消えた。100
点のテスト事件。おららららう。
[拍手]
[音楽]
おい、聞いたが免許なんてお前く相手でも悪くなったか?僕はいつもテストで
60点しか取れないけど、100
点を取ったらお小遣いがもらえることになったんだ。聞いた?テストで
点取ったらお小遣いあげるから頑張りなさい。
え、頑張る。
それで念願のスイッチ2
を買うんだ。だからたくさん勉強してるんだよ。
きちゃんこ休み時間に勉強はダサすぎるよ。今更コ売ったって無駄なんよ。
[拍手]
でもお遣いがもらえるから
僕のお金持ちだからおコいらない。
みんなどれくらい勉強した?全然してた。
落ちるわけないよ。勉強するもんないんよ。
はい。よいスタート。読んだら満てないよ。
[音楽]
おい、お前何やってんだな。何って答え見てるんよ、この人間の。あ。
はい、じゃあテスト終わり。回収するぞ。はい。はい、じゃあテスト返すぞ。じ、
0点だったよ。
50点。90点だった。
あ、聞いた。何点だった?あ、100。
100点だった。すげえ。
きーちゃんとも点数悪い。同士なのにのきが書きしてずるいよ。あ、
[音楽]
[拍手]
す、取り行きたいから連れしよう。
いいよ。
はい。じゃあ今日は終わり。さようなら。
さようなら。
ない。え?ない。ない。僕の100
点のテストがない。盗まれた。事件だ。名探偵屋根介。
え?何やってんの?
あ、ちょっと放課後コスプレの予定があって時間です。
ふむふむ。それで容疑者は誰か?
犯人はこの3人の誰かだ?ええ。
休み時間に僕と根助がトイレに行ってる間に誰かが僕のテストを盗んだんだ。
おい、ミュート。お前らお前聞いたがいい転数を取ったことに嫉妬してたし、カンニングもしてたし。
違うよ。僕は食べ物以外は取らんのよ。怪しい。犯人は歌言うとお前だ。
[音楽]
めぐれケブお見事。
相当決まるわ。おし置きえ。どのあ、
僕じゃないよ。僕じゃないよ。
何かがおかしい。
そうか。
[音楽]
違う。犯人はお前だな。こじり。
え、な、なんでだ?
歌言うとはバカだから点数が欲しいかもしれないけど、こいつには親がないから
100点を取っても意味がない。
でも私90点を取ってるわよ。
だからお前が犯人なんだ。靴下を脱いでみな。女の子なのに靴下を自分から臭いというのはありえないはずだ。
靴下に髪を隠すためのカモフラージだったんだろ。
動くの?
[音楽]
こじりは勉強してないと言ってめちゃめちゃ裏で勉強するタイプの嫌な嘘つき。プライドが高くてこじりがこの中で
1番じゃなきゃ嫌だったんだろ。
そうなの。
本当はたくさん勉強したのに100
点が取れなくて
90点でも十分すごいことだよ。
ちなみに屋根し君はテスト何点だったの?
僕は天才だから勉強しなくても100
点だった。え、お前
これにて事件。
この体勢血に頭が登るよ。
[拍手]
小学生女子誘拐事件がS
を荒らしててお前らお前ら分かったな。明日は楽しい遠足だ。はい。さよなら。
[拍手]
[音楽]
遠遠速遠速遠
よしら1時間19系だんで来い。
うわ、クワガ。
クワガダンス。クワガダンス。ハム。
クワガダンス。クダス。ハム。
[音楽]
[笑い]
こじちゃん。面白いね。へ。
この人誰?マネージャーだよ。
マネージャーです。マネージャー。
私この人にスカウトされて小役デビューしたの。
ほら、私お兄ちゃんのことがすぐが好きなの。
[笑い]
[音楽]
あ、おせじにもうまいとは言えねえ。
この子は天才女優なんだ。
最近知らない男の人にストーカーされてたんだけど、この人がついてきてくれるおかげでストーカーがなくなったの。
へえ。アトマシ捕まえたんよ。
いいな。俺も捕まえっと。
見つけた。やった。
ダブルなよ。
うわー。いっぱい、いっぱい。
もう紐くれるから帰るぞ。
ん?こじりがいない。
僕も探してたんですけどどっか消えちゃって。
もしかして誰かに連れされたか?お前ら帰ってろ。俺は警察を呼ぶ。
はい。はい。
僕は最後向こうで見たで向こうの方を探していきます。事務所の対応丸でお願いします。
事件だ。
俺の出番だ。名探偵屋根助。それで疑いにある人物は誰?
[音楽]
そうだ。あいつだ。少女漫画を見ながらこっちの方を見ていた不審者がいたぞ。
確かに怪しい逮捕だ。俺にて事件解決。お見が。
[音楽]
いや、そしたらこんじりはどこにいるんだ?もしもし、こじりか。
助けて。捕まえられてる。ボールのところに。あ、
[拍手]
そう。が喋りやがって。
[音楽]
こじり、こじり。
ということはこいつは一体何なんだ?
僕はただの少女漫画だ。話せ。
くそ。こじりはどこにいるんだ?
お、あのマネジャーから電話だ。
こじりの靴が西の方で見つかったので僕はそろを探します。
なるほど。西の方でキラキラボール。キラキラボール。パチンコだ。パチンコ。パチンコ。パチンコ。パチンコ。
ここから1
番近いパチンコ店は西の隣町にあるパチンコ屋です。そこに行きましょう。
行くぞ。
パチンコ、パチンコ、パチンコ、パチンコ。
いや、おかしい。パチンコ店だったら何か音が聞こえるはず。それにそのお店は徒歩で
1時間半もかかるぞ。何かヒントは?
そうだ。
ケブ、私の可愛い生徒のために私もさんに協力します。行こ。
よし、修を探すぞ。はい。
待ってろ。こんじり。公園から徒歩で30
分圏内。キラキラボールはこれだったのか。
でもどこにいるんだ?虫。なるほど。あっちか。
[音楽]
こん。
お前なぜここへった?簡単さ。
[音楽]
虫の対列がトントンツツツトントンでボール信号の
SOS
[音楽]
になっていたのさ。こじりが好きな曲だ。こじりが虫を話して助けを求めたんだろう。
いっぱいいっぱい安いス
こじりを晴して大しく警察に捕まったらどうだ?マネージャーさんよ。なぜ俺だと分かった?
[音楽]
お前は根りに恋をしたんだろう?
ストーカーをしていたお前はどうにかこじりに近づく方法を考えた。それで嘘のスカウトをして嘘の撮影までもした。
あんな下手な演技で映画に出れるはずなんてない。こじりをこの近くに脱致した後戻ってきてバを作った。はの方に行くので
[音楽]
その後は靴の位置を嘘ついて俺らを騙したってわけだ。
そうだ。俺はこの美少女に恋をしたんだ。今日告学して普通に振られたからこうやって捕まえてしまった。
こじさん好きだ。付き合ってくれ。
おじさんは無理。ガーし。
くそ。
こじちゃんは絶対俺のものにしてやれ。
このひモ男が。バローンじりをもう話せ。
もう怒ったぞ。まずい。
当たれ当たれ当たれ当たれ当たれ。え、
ハワイ先生、今すぐ来てください。な
んだ今いいとこなんだ。よっしゃ、当たるな。これでもうバちください。
ああ、もう真実の相真実は相信真実はし実は相
サッカーボールはいつもそ
あおこいつです。
うあお
あ、なんか犯人はすでに倒れてたよ。ごじじゃないか。こんじ、こんち大丈夫か?大丈夫か?
先生が助けてくれたの?
そうだ。先生が必死に探して犯人を捕まえた。もう安心しろ。
全然ありがとう。
今後は気をつけろよ。
やれやれ。嘘ばっかり。まいっか。回答キット。
V根助。はあ、疲れたな。
そうだな。屋根介君の手柄だよ。
お前誰だ?
見せてもらってよ。君が令和のシャーロックホームズ。名探偵屋根助か。
お前は。
俺は回答キット。どんなものも鮮やかに盗む。大回答さ。
君と勝負がしたい。
大怪答ね。お前を捕まえてやるよ。
あれはなんだ?行くぞ。はい。お前は噂の回答キットだな。捕まえてやる。
見失った。あ、い。な
んだこれは?2月18
日うの誕生日パーティーに行て本物のポケモンカードをいただきに参生する回答キット。なるほど。
勝負ってわけだな。ジュ誕生日パーティーで改道キットがお前のカードを盗めに来るらしい。行ってもいいか?
やれす君は頭いいからいいよ。でも誰も盗めないと思うけどね。
ありがとう。え?じゃ、
歌は貧乏だからダめ。本気で足やからだめ。たはうんちもら。
[音楽]
おい、順、なんか参加品みたいなのをもらえるのか?
僕の家はお金持ちだから参加所にはプレゼントがあるよ。
よし、先生を行く。助け1
人だと心も持たないからな。カリカリ
お前て本当に金持ちなんだな。
う順誕生日おめでとう。
ありがとう。甘井先生は誘ってないんだけど。
やらす、うんの誕生日会だからビシッとしろよ。で、うろじ参加品は
あ、後で渡すね。
私お金持ちなので高いポケカは全部持っているのですが、うどじん君のポケカは本当にレアですごいです。いいな、いいな。
[音楽]
えへへ。
本当に金持ちばっかり集まってるんだな。金持ちは性格悪いから嫌いだなあ。す、
うどん君の先生ですね。リュフェをどうぞ。
[音楽]
え、いいんですか?ありがとうございます
。ありがとうございます。よっしゃ、成功
。イエー
。ダしダしダしこしこしちでしょ
[音楽]
僕の誕に来てくれてありがとう。楽しんでる。そしてこれがペアカールだよ。
僕の家金持ちだからこんなのすぐ変えちゃうんだ。ただ回答キットが盗みにくいらしいから皆さんには偽物を配りました。僕のも本物かわかんないんだ。これで盗まれないね。
おお。
たった1
枚のカード騒いで何が楽しいのかね。ビュッフェも少なかったし。
[音楽]
お前は飯ではしゃぎすぎだろ。
んおめでとう。おめでとう。
おめでとうじ。
[音楽]
僕のカードがない。僕のが本物だったんだ。
え?ない?ない?ない。僕のカード僕のカードがない。僕のカードがない。僕のカード。
そう。回答キットはどこだ?
事件ですか?盗難事件だ。
怪しいやつを集めろ。はい。
何が悪い?何?
こんなやつが紛れ込んでいました。
僕はご飯が食べたかっただけなんよ。うジョンが誘ってくれんから。エビ
[拍手]
ん。勝手に侵入して。しかも貧乏。怪しい。こいつが回答キットだ。逮捕。
ええ。なんでなんでなんで?
警部お見事です。
回答せ。
え、違うよ。僕はただのピンポになるよ。さよ。さないよ。
やめらしやめらし。もうなんないよ。防衛はきたいよ。
取れないの?何かがおかしい。
ハ先生キットの居場所が分かりました。ついてきてください。
おお。
う、やめるなし。う、僕はたったの貧乏にいて。
[音楽]
こんなとこにキットがいるのか?
そうだ。俺の目の前にな。なあ、回答キット。
え、まがカードに興味を持たないのはおかしかった。
だってまお金が大好きだから。
たった1
枚のカードで騒いて何が楽しいのかね。
お前は先生がフ選んでる間に過り替わったんだろ。そして爆弾を仕込みう転せてカードを盗んだ。う的に人を見下していて高なカードを他人に触らせたくないのでうジンが持っているのは当たり前だったんだ。すごいね。名探偵屋根助
[音楽]
出たな。回答キット。
ほらでも大事なものを1
つ忘れていないかい?がいない。はどこだ?ゾビザ。
先生大丈夫ですか?大丈夫ですか?
怪鮮やかに獲物を盗び立つ。想像的な芸術家だが、探偵はその後を見てランク性をつける。ただの会に過ぎねえんだぜ。
[音楽]
ない。カードがない。取られてたと。この俺をくとはな。お面しれえ。また来いよ。カイトキット。次は絶対捕まえてやる。
[笑い]
僕のカードは
お前は金持ちなんだからまた変え。拍。人気だったら続くかも。
[音楽]